these are really historic times in
sports never before have players had
such a strong and loud voice sports
director chris matthews joining us now
in studio
with more on some major decisions being
made by players in their respective
leagues
well thank you brian yeah this is
historic because all the leagues are now
paying close attention
to the voices of those who play the game
collective voices who are asking for a
sustainable change the nba boycotted its
games yesterday
today the nhl will do the same there are
no hockey games today
or tomorrow players standing united in a
cause for
sustainable change last night the league
recognized what's going on in the world
today
all the players from the bubble in
edmonton gathering in a show of support
and it started with golden knights
forward ryan reeves
talking to players back east and then
with vancouver players here in the west
bubble
talking and making a collective
statement was their mission
but also understanding that change won't
happen overnight but
collectively shining a light on racial
injustice
right now is a strong start there's a
lot of uh
there's a lot of white athletes in here
and i think that's the statement that's
being made right now
you know it's great that the nba did
this and then they'll be in the wnba
you know they have a lot of black
players in those leagues but for
you know all these athletes in here
to take a stand and say you know what we
we see the problem too
and we stand behind you you know i go to
war with these guys and i
hate their guts on ice but i couldn't be
more proud of these guys it's
you know the statement they've made
today is is something that's going to
last
all right now the nba will resume its
playoffs and eventually the wnba nba
will play again but not tonight the
women's games canceled las vegas seattle
scheduled to play
for first place in the league but the
league postponed those games also